the jogan experience I don't know
exactly what's happening all I know is
very short clips that I found in the
internet but the funniest thing is this
one guy on Twitter that was saying a
while back uh I live on a a ground floor
apartment and I hear Jews underneath
me and every it's like you're out of
your [__] mind that's anti-semitic
exactly and now he's like I told you I
wasn't crazy but this gu was you but
what are they doing like I I heard that
they hired people to build like this
tunnel and they were hanging out and
like the people would live there for
like three weeks these like migrant
workers were just digging this tunnel
and they stayed there for 3 weeks but
what's the purpose of it I have no idea
I have no idea I don't know anything I
just know that there's tunnels and that
this there's this one video of this guy
coming out of the sewer so he lifts a
manhole cover comes out of the sewer and
then he's [__] wandering around this
hidic Jewish guy and everybody's like
what the [__] you you doing down there
yeah that's really bizarre they wouldn't
come out too the cops had to get them
out like they were like we don't want to
come out and they were like charged with
disorderly conduct or I I don't know the
whole [__] world is just weird what
do you know about this Jamie
anything I haven't heard anything yeah
the best I've gotten is that that they
started making them during Co but that
like it line it makes sense but it also
you see the tunnels you're like no way
that's not you didn't do that in two
years or a year or six months whatever
it was they weren't exactly nice tunnels
either they were just kind of shitty
rudimentary basic h like were they were
they doomsdayers that they thought the
world was going to
end wait a minute the tunnels are so big
that you don't think they could make
them in two years is that what you're
saying some of them look big it's like
how do you I mean some of them are
saying they go mult they going to
multiple different buildings it's like a
series of tunnels it's not just a tunnel
let's let's look into this they're still
looking into it I don't know like that M
discover was it yesterday it's only been
discovered a couple years ago I forget
how couple years ago days ago uh some I
forget even how discovered it I think
they were looking um probably that guy
complaining he probably heard something
and and then maybe they saw somebody
come out the manhole cover and somebody
put two and two together I've no idea
what happened yeah it's strange but it's
very bizarre and then of course there's
conspiracy theories and what are they
doing down there and evil evil theories
they immediately want to pour concrete
in it which makes sense because it's
probably not safe you got it's not
supporting the weight of the you know
all the buildings above it yeah you
don't think of that when you move into
an apartment building that some [__]
might build a tunnel underneath and
collapse the [__] collapse the
building on
you imagine if you're on the ground
floor and you're like why does my floor
have so much G these [__] are
building a sinkhole under my house yeah
I don't uh but it's funny how like
things are so crazy like you read about
something like that and it doesn't even
stand out that much like we talk about
it now and then tomorrow be some other
weird [__] like every day it's something
weird it's something crazy yeah yeah
it's way more than ever before yeah what
you got what you got Jamie so here's
what the New York news was saying like
happened on Monday afternoon I guess so
it's very new something about tunneling
yeah which is so crazy yeah that's such
a commitment isn't it interesting like
if you build on top of a building it's
no big deal but you go under the
building like what are you doing yeah
you're really destabilizing you're in a
tunnel for several hours police pleaded
with the young men to leave the entrance
to the tunnel according to the witnesses
after they refused the officers covered
the area with a wire curtain and entered
the dusty crass with zip ties to detain
the protesters
when they took the first person out with
zip ties that's when the Outburst
happened brou Dahan a 21-year-old study
of the synagogue who videotaped the
congregants fighting almost everyone was
against what they did but as soon as
people saw the handcuffs there was
confusion and pushing footage posted to
social media shows scores of onlookers
mostly young men jeering at the nypd's
community fairs officers some lifted
wooden desks into the air sending prayer
Brooks scattering in response the
officer appeared to deploy an irritating
spray to disperse the
group so how did they find out about
this I don't know but even after hearing
that I still know nothing about what
they were doing or why I think they're
just starting to trying to figure out so
so scroll down a little it didn't have a
good like explanation on what the
initial call was for and I was trying to
I was going to switch to a different
article that and why they being called
protesters like what would they protest
if you're just sitting in a tunnel is
that actually a protest everyone's a
protester and everyone's an activist
yeah uh officials and locals said young
men in the community recently built the
passage to the sanctuary in secret when
the group's leaders tried to seal it off
on Monday they staged a protest that
turned violent as police moved in to
make
arrests how long does it take to make a
tunnel they I I'm assuming a couple
years if it went that uh that far find a
different it all depends entirely on
what's down there already were they
putting po dirt in their pockets like
[__] Shaw Shank that's what they said
they were doing they had like dirt in
their pockets saw that as a joke I don't
know
if oh boy [__] Endeavor what a rough
time for the Jews it is yeah yeah this
doesn't they're getting it from all
angles they really are and then this on
top of that and and it's like the whole
the whole planet just hates each other
everybody [__] hates each other it's
weird right it is I don't even think
it's about the issues I don't think
people necessarily people believe what
they believe but I think it's more the
the addiction to arguing and the
addiction to being angry like no matter
what the
people just hate each other if they give
if someone gives the wrong answer the
people who think it's the wrong answer
hate your
guts